>> Ken: IOOD SEASON.
A GREAT RYAN GRAVES.
MARCUS FOLIGNO.
CONCENTRATION WITH
MA TO GO FIVE HOLE.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A BEAUTY
HAMILTON OFF THE BOARDS.WAY.
PULLING TWO-ON-ONE SHORT  THERE.
.
COACHES AND MANAGERS REALLY
GRAVES HAVE SLOTTED IN?
>> Ken: NOTHEY COME OUT STORMIN
TALBOT IS JUST FINDING SATURDAY.
GOES WIDE.
THE LOOSE PUCK.
BACK FOR SEVERSON.
THE BLOCKED SHOTTALBOT, NOT THE
GOALPOST.
THE MID SECTION A LOT.
HE BREAKS ON.
DROPS IT BACK.
SEVERSON.
RIGHT
SPEED MOST OF THE PERIOD. ARE P
17th GAME OF THE SEAS SCORE! FO
THE MINNESOTA WILD.
INT.
SEVERSON.S ONE.
SHOOTING, THAT EQUALIZER
BECAUSE THEY WERE MOVING THE
LI.
DROPS HERE FOR STICK ON IT AS W.
DOUGIE HAMILTON LEADS THE WAY.W.
GOT THE PANEL OUT.
AND DOUGIE TRIED TOL BE MATS
ZUCCARELLO TO GET THINGS STARTE!
>> Ken: HE'S
JESPER BRATT LIKE A LOTMOVE.
BRATT.
STEPPED OUT, SAVE MADE, ALLOW BA